If you had the opportunity to go
and view any culture from the past,
like if you can be completely invisible
and walk around amongst the Romans or
cave people or native Americans
before the Europeans came,
what would you choose?
Wow,
that's really hard question.
Yeah.
MMM.
The first time where anything
was trying to be colonized,
like changed like the first time,
like a boat showed up in Polynesia or
something like that and some white people
got out,
right?
We're used to being in the fields every
day and this guy hunts and this guy
watches after the boys
and teaches them and,
and then all of a sudden they come up
and they're building like you guys need
to,
why you live in,
he calls for Color Cox are the women are
staring at their fucking balls two feet
from the ground.
What are these things?
I,
they my,
what the fuck is going
on price please guys.
Got To fucking look at his hair.
It's chunked off his fucking Tito.
He's got bones in his fucking air price.
Can I get a Bible
lesson?
And there was this
thing called Noah's Ark.
Sit down.
He's fuckers.
Don't pay attention.
Get you fucking round them up.
Me and the boys,
we're going to need about
40 these fucking things.
Climb trees is your character's name.
I love the guy.
He needs to come back more often.
This is the kind of say,
Geez,
Joe,
they climb trees.